benvenuti al grande fratello visto sia
sempre di più il cuore
misco pessima messo per scopi a voi non
avete idea che emozione siamo di nuovo
qua dopo un anno siamo pronti io sono
pronta a voi siete pronti e quindi dire
di collegarci subito immediatamente con
la piscina della casa dove incontreremo
il primo con no vabbè 9 a cristiano
cristiano mi senti e galan di due gal
dall'acqua cristiano cristiano niente
cristiano non ci sente quindi direi di
non perdere tempo e collegarci con la
passerella dove c'è la seconda nostra
opinionista del cuore sto parlando di
iva zanicchi amore you grazie grazie
ragazzi c'è un entusiasmo fantastico e
credibile
bene dopo aver presentato i nostri
opinionisti supertop direi di passare
subito alla presentazione alla clip del
primo concorrente sono ivano icardi
ho 23 anni sono argentina mi dispiace
avere questa voce che sembrò loredano
aver tre sono la sorella de mauro icardi
che è un grande giocatore e gioca
nell'inter era portato mio fratello si è
rovinato dal momento che c'è una persona
nella sua vita che non mi convince e sta
con questa moglie che sino fosse
calciatore mai starebbe con lui sono
arrabbiata delusa
finalmente sono arrivati in studio i
miei due opinioniste che ho voluto
tantissimo con me sto parlando di
cristiano malgioglio iva zanicchi
ciao a tutti buona vera per sé molto
omogenea te sai barbara buonasera grazie
grazie
no vabbè cristiano ma ma ce li ha e le
mutandine
bè che c'è non è mai visto un uomo
panini del crispiano vi farò che cosa è
lì sotto
frutta e verdura tesoro vieni a vivere
dai dai che te lo faccio vedere
lasciamo perdere cristiano e passiamo
alla seconda clip del secondo
concorrente che tra l'altro ti vuole
molto bene cristiano sa di chi sto
parlando
sto parlando di noi il ciclone lemme al
grande fratello
tuoni fulmini sempre dopo di me la casa
non sarà più la stessa cosa siete
ciccioli o diversamente secchi il genio
in arrivo a presto
ci mancava solo lui l'anno scorso
dichiara come si chiamava quella liga
spagnola
aida è quest'anno c'è lui ma se i
cristiano vedrai che diventerete ottimi
amici
passiamo subito al terzo concorrente a
vignali ho 27 anni non sono una da
rimini va più a roma nella vita sono una
modella un influencer cestista guarda
bottone grossa busta c tua i miei amici
mi chiamano vigna lona per ovvie ragioni
fisiche
quindi state molto attenti sono stata
fidanzata cinque anni e mezzo e ci avevo
pure creduto se lui mi sta sia alla casa
del grande fratello rimarrebbe fuori e
sotto la pioggia con un piccione che li
dava in testa e adesso è arrivato il
momento di un ragazzo che io adoro ha
una voce pazzesca e sono sicura che
tutti voi vi ricorderete di lui
ciao mi chiamo christian o vendite anni
e vengo da palermo il caldo una passione
che ho da quando avevo 5 anni
cantavo i telecomandi in mano
sono fuori dal balcone i vicini di casa
mi urlavano di smettere
poi è arrivato io canto che è stato il
mio grandissimo trampolino di lancio con
un caratterino un po spigoloso e se
vengo stuzzica diventa una di pena
sicuramente l'immagine dell'angioletto
di io canto morirà proprio andrà nel
dimenticatoio
nel cesso e dopo il nostro christian
parliamo di una donna di una ragazza che
ha da poco voltato pagina
sto parlando di lei ciao sono mila ho 31
anni e faccio la modella sono nate
cresciute marocco fino all'età di 12
anni
poi mi sono trasferita in italia con mio
papà forse mi avrete già vista in
giornali o tv perché ero fidanzata con
alex belli noi sognavamo una famiglia di
sposarci over figli
e invece mi ha tradito oggi alex è
ancora fidanzato con quella con cui mi
ha tradito chi è una donna senza
identità
entra nella casa del grande fratello con
il cuore libero ma ancora diciamo un
pochino spezzate e lo sto facendo
piano che non tenuti a concludere questa
carrellata dei nostri concorrenti del
grande fratello 16 con un personaggio
totalmente fuori dalle righe
e proprio per questo motivo io lo adoro
che si chiama enrico contare in grande
fratello quando ci sei io ci sono
ciao sono enrico contarino 26 anni sono
diverse gae lavoro nell'azienda di
famiglia per 19 anni era un madrelingua
veneto parlamo veneto con tutti poi ho
fatto la valigia direzione capoluogo
lombardo e mi sono iscritto
all'università
nessuno si aspettava conto set come
miccia passi due lauree una la cavani
tanti ma do tutto quello che goda fare
se lavorare vendere borse e fa quel che
mi dice mio papà eccoci purtroppo
arrivati al termine di questa prima
meravigliosa puntata prima di salutarvi
ci terrei anche a salutare i nostri due
opinionisti top cristiano
amore e iva ciao a tutte grazie grazie e
ciao amore
se volete una seconda puntata della
parodia del grande fratello 16 fatemelo
sapere qui sotto mi raccomando se non lo
avete ancora fatto mi raccomando
iscrivetevi al canale di marina perché è
super top io la adoro eseguite la su
tutti gli altri social facebook tik tok
e instagram
non mi resta che dire una cosa che non
dico mai col cuore perché nel mio cuore
ci sono prima di figli ma subito dopo ci
siete voi col cuore col cuore adoro